you know all my children is responsible
for my entire life
um and when i i don't like say that
lightly i mean i met my husband
on all my children i had my children on
all my children
i got this job in standing in my
dressing room on all my children it's
like
it that is responsible for my entire
life and
i'm not being glib when i say that well
it's great to see you too i know you've
got a big week ahead of you with your
virtual road trip
so let's get to it what do the two of
you miss most about traveling and when
this is all over
what's the first place you'd love to
escape to oh my god
i want to i want to retire in palm
springs so i'm very
excited that i'm getting a jump start on
this
i'm going to take a virtual real estate
tour to go with our virtual
kelly actually a photo was sent in from
a viewer
of kelly's home that she's going to
purchase from this viewer because she
liked the backyard so much
so that's her plan what about you ryan
where do you want to go
i want to go to beaches i want to go i
actually want to go
overseas i would love to go have some
really good italian food i would love to
gallivant you know go far far far away
ryan's gonna be the where's waldo
he will be we're gonna name we're gonna
rename ryan waldo because yeah we'll
have a hard time following
you yeah that will be the next week on
on
live for sure okay so you guys are
visiting palm springs of course kelsey
you're getting your
your uh virtual tour of your uh you know
future retirement place austin
miami i'm disappointed nashville's not
in the mix but that's okay
but when you guys do travel what do you
like to indulge in is it the beaches
the sights the food what is it
you know i have to say that um we
the consuelos family we like to go
off the beaten path we we try to not
have a schedule and we just
construct where the people that live
there
yeah so instead of relying on
say like what a travel agent
would recommend or what a travel company
might recommend
we tend to ask local people
where do you like to eat or where do you
like to go and we sort of
let we do we wander we're a bit we're
spontaneous we're nomadic and
spontaneous when it comes to travel
whereas
i only travel for the food like i love
to pick places that have great
authenticity that's the guy who likes to
eat air
um i love air air is great i feel like
it's necessary
a glass box of air every now and again
keeps him
right on track kelly i will plan my
meals for months before i take a trip
i like it i like both of your styles
it's good i want a new i want to know
the rest of your style though because
you know how i love to play a game with
the two of you so
we're going to play a game if kelly and
ryan went on a road trip
are you ready for it it's a speed room
one answer
one word answer if possible guys okay if
the two of you took a road trip
who would drive i would drive
i don't trust her driving doesn't drive
that much
so that's settled he was singing in this
car
a hundred percent more rapping but yes i
would be
actually and the two of us like to sing
some 80s love songs
yeah and hey ryan as long as you're not
dancing buddy as long as you're not
dancing
no i can't dance rachel i just want to
say one thing i do believe that ryan
now has me confused with somebody else
no no kelly and i
love to sing air supply foreigner
mary manilow we do quite a do we do it
well
as a very yeah i'll give you barry i'll
give you barry okay
all right calling outside all right fine
who's the backseat driver
me kelly and also the front seat driver
by the way
all the drivers who would be getting
more texts from the family
wait wait more texts from from ryan's
family me
that would be me who would you would
kelly be getting more texts from her
family or would ryan be getting more let
me explain how it works
my family texts kelly more than me
so kelly would get texts from her family
and my family
i love it but usually all of our texts
are discussing ryan in some way
naturally right
of course finally who would post the
most on their social media
me of course yes
now kelly ripa what do you make of the
fan excitement of the development of
pine valley everyone stoked about it and
why was now the right time
and and what was the last part why is
now the right time
um i just feel like you know in the
grand
scheme of every thing being what it is
soap opera fans are the original super
fan
you know soap opera fans pre-date
comic-con they pre-date
even american idol they pre-date all of
these super fandoms of super fandoms
and so um i just feel like there's so
much rich storytelling left to do
and um you know all my children is
responsible for my entire life
um and when i i i don't like say that
lightly i mean i met my husband
on all my children i had my children
on all my children i got this job in
standing in my dressing room on all my
children it's like
it that is responsible for my entire
life and
i'm not being glib when i say that i
actually that's i mean that
so um it's been something we've talked
about for years believe it or not
when all my children went off the air i
was devastated
not for myself because i had left the
show by then but i was devastated for
the fan base because it means so much to
them it's true about the shows i owe my
career to ryan's hope
and your name wasn't that one of the
soaps yes
yes yes yes exactly you do owe a lot to
american idol ryan seacrest and you guys
are back
for another season and it is you guys
are having so much fun
the talent i feel like every year it
gets better and better and of course
i feel like that's a little cliche to
say but my gosh last night was amazing
how much fun do you have with three
judges
the judges now are so comfortable with
each other that they can stay
anything i mean they trust each other
they can say anything to each other
40 makes the show then there's a lot
that they can't put on tv
um so they have a good time but the
talent that comes in and i'm always
impressed
by you know the story of a guy
who's working at a factory who's never
really sung before in front of people
and he walks in he's got this amazing
voice
and that to me is what the essence of
american idol is
yeah but i just love seeing the the
chemistry between
all four of y'all what's the best part
about being on the road with them during
the audition process ryan
well i mean first of all they're
superstars so it's kind of fun for me to
hang out with three superstars
uh lionel is the
most amazing nicest human being
you'll ever meet and spend time with
katie has a wicked sense of humor
and luke has a lot of beers